[Music]
Hello. Hello.
Allah
[Music]
all that juice. That juice. That juice.
[Applause]
[Music]
Today we're going to be doing a deep
dive into the obvious cult of Islam.
Now, I know just because I say it's
obvious doesn't mean that it's
automatically true. So, you know what
we're going to do? We are going to go
point for point about why Islam is a
cult. First point, apostasy. To convert
or to embrace Islam. Yeah. What would
happen the day that I say, you know,
I've changed my mind. I want to leave
Islam again. See, this is a very very
hypothetical question because if
you accept Islam
wholeheartedly, it is very very very
unlikely that you will just come at one
point and say, "Well, I changed my
mind." It's hypothetical, but it's a
clear question. Yeah. But a clear
question. It doesn't mean that it does
exist. Young accept Islam. Enjoy the
Islam. And once you want to leave it, we
will discuss it. Yeah. That's like
taking a big chance. Spot me. Do this in
in in But what is it so hard to to to
answer? He doesn't want to answer the
question. Not so hard. But but it is so
hard for you to understand it. But
what's the answer? Yeah, it is hard for
you to understand it. It is hard for the
viewers to understand it. But come on,
come on. Come on. Come on. Give up. Give
up. Just say I gave
up. Just say I gave up.